simulate things that no one has ever
done before like dropping millions of
tons of trash into a volcano dropping
phone cases down into the Mariana Trench
shooting all the world's plastic out
into space and more where are we getting
these crazy ideas well a couple of weeks
ago we asked you the what if Community
where you wanted us to dispose of the
world's trash and you guys delivered
some wild ideas now we're going to show
them to you like never before but before
we get to that we're gonna drop this
into melted glass at over 1 000 degrees
Celsius this is about as hot as lava
which should give us a pretty good idea
of what might happen if we were to throw
our garbage into a volcano so this is
copper but if I actually threw my
garbage in here or my phone case which
is made of plastic it would just fill
the room with all the fumes from the
chemicals that make it and we would
probably die okay that was pretty cool
but what if we were to do this in an
actual volcano with way more trash using
our super cool video effects team let's
find out this is you your trash
not you are trash your trash the amount
of trash you create in one year and
we're about to throw it into a volcano
but wait
I don't see a volcano
VFX team
that's better the lava inside this
volcano is over 1200 degrees Celsius and
this is 680 kilograms of trash now if
you don't know how big that is well
picture a polar bear but they're made of
trash thanks VFX team
if you were to drop this much waste into
a volcano well you're looking at a big
explosion you see since the lava inside
the volcano is so hot and our trash is
relatively cool well that equals boom
the trash would hit the lava and trigger
a reaction of pressurized and acidic
Steam
that was pretty intense but we're not
going to stop there we've got a whole
lot more trash to get rid of let me talk
to Marina about this the animation you
made of one person's trash really good
but I'm thinking up it quite a bit more
than one person okay what do you have in
mind like 20 million people
seriously okay New York City's trash for
a year we roll it all up into a ball and
throw that into a volcano okay how much
trash is that 14 million tons I'll need
some time to figure it out can you give
me some time and I'll get back to you I
can give you a couple more minutes
because there's only a few minutes left
in the video yeah go ahead thanks
okay perfect while we wait for that
let's jump over to the other side of the
world
but first why are we doing this well the
world's got a bit of a trash problem
plastic in the ocean food wastes
hundreds of tons of it the garbage
reality is bigger than you might realize
and our friends at Taste if I have been
working hard to solve it more on that
later but for now we're gonna take a
crack at it that's why we challenged you
to help us figure out the best way to
get rid of garbage from food waste to
plastic packaging to phone cases this
one says hey Peter the trash in our
ocean how do we get rid of it maybe dump
it into the Mariana Trench I like your
thinking over 14 million tons of trash
end up in the ocean every year that's
over 8 trillion pieces of plastic and a
big part of this trash problem is old
phone cases over one and a half billion
of them are thrown away every year so
we're gonna have to find a way to get
rid of all those old phone cases what if
we dump them down into the deepest part
ocean Marina do your thing
we're bringing you down 11
000 meters to the bottom of the Mariana
Trench since the Mariana Trench is the
deepest point on Earth dumping one and a
half billion phone cases should be
nothing for this ocean Cavern
in theory the Mariana Trench could hold
over one trillion phone cases in it
it's forcing our phone cases to be
compressed smaller and smaller
the pressure of the Mariana Trench is
comparable to a tower of 2 000 elephants
stacked up on top of each other and
sitting on your head
and as hundreds of millions of phone
cases pile up we'd be shocked at how
horrible it is for the ocean materials
leak out into the sea killing ocean
wildlife and destroying coral reefs not
to mention leaking more and more
microplastics into the water I wonder
what would happen if we sent it up into
space instead well more on that soon
anyways that was a bad idea I think I've
found a better way to get rid of our old
phone cases but first let's check in
with our giant ball of trash going into
the volcano
foreign
looks like they're still working on it
okay well while it's being assembled let
me take a minute to tell you what we're
going to do to fix our phone case waste
problem if I ever have to throw out a
phone case I'm giving mine the case defy
they've got the world's largest phone
case recycling program all you do is
send them your old phone case and
they'll upcycle it for you producing a
completely new one not only does this
create a new case but it also prevents a
case from joining the landfill this
video wouldn't be possible without case
defy so to thank them and to help out
this channel so that we can do more
videos like this check out case defies
website so you can learn more about how
to upcycle your old phone case you can
get a new cooler case like this yeah I'm
never throwing this out oh sweet looks
like our massive pile of trash is ready
to be thrown into the volcano now let's
drop it in
this time instead of creating a massive
explosion inside the volcano this trash
ball is going to create an explosion
that goes hundreds of meters up in the
air lava would spread to every nearby
town and the pollution oh the pollution
without a filter dropping this much
trash into a hot lava lake would spread
poisonous fumes for hundreds of meters
this doesn't look good
okay that was
a really bad idea
but I'm gonna give you guys another
another chance oh that's an idea that's
out of this world
literally
we're going to see what would happen if
we bring our garbage up into space and
launch it into the Sun but instead of
our garbage how about we switch it up a
bit let's just move our plastic waste
we've got a ton of that or should I say
tons about 40 million tons of plastic is
thrown out every year and that's just in
the United States
maybe we should strap it all to a rocket
and send it into the sun that's probably
the best way to get rid of it what do
you think you can simulate this for us
no I think we can but I'm gonna need
some help can you go collect a bag of
plastic garbage and see how much that
would weigh seriously yeah yeah I think
I can figure that out I'll be right back
finally
let's do this well I'm out here picking
up trash
let's see what other ideas you guys have
come up with stomach acid
ah no as strong as stomach acid is it
wouldn't be able to dissolve all our
trash and how would you even get that
much stomach acid for it to do anything
what about a black hole
yeah but it's theoretically impossible
and it would kill everyone involved so
next could we send it back in time
and that would just mess up the world
even more today
Okay Marina I think I think I got enough
okay how much is it well it's pretty
heavy well I need an accurate
measurement
right of course I'll send you the
details on how much it weighs
okay so how do we do let's see
sending our plastic into space would
require one million bags full of any
plastic trash and to get that up into
the sky would require 640
000 Rockets
and blowing up a rocket in the sun isn't
as easy as it sounds the only way we'd
be able to get our Rockets into the sun
would be if we slowed the Rockets down
by 30 kilometers per second
which is extremely hard to do
that's because Earth moves around the
Sun at 30 kilometers per second so in
order to line up the rocket with our sun
it would need to stop all its sideways
momentum and that would be almost
impossible to properly time and line up
so it doesn't look that great huh well
no it will look more like this
oh yeah not a great idea
um looks like these crazy ideas aren't
going to work maybe the best thing we
could do is just recycle I mean it
sounds too good to be true but recycling
really does work if we all did it we'd
notice reduced pollution and more
vibrant natural resources it can also
create some pretty awesome phone cases
shout out again to case defy so instead
of wasting a bunch of money or risking
our lives with these crazy ideas all you
have to do is this
oh so hopefully we can all play a small
role in fixing the world's trash problem
but what should we tackle next
well that's a story or another
what if